the original songs for four town in  turning red were written by billy eilish  and phineas o'connell phineas also  provided the voice for jesse and he said  he left at the opportunity to write the  songs and voice the character jordan  fisher voiced robert and loved blending  his experience in voice acting and music  to bring his character to life whenever  i can blend any worlds together at all  i'm thrilled grayson villanueva voiced  tae young the la nueva is an  award-winning vocal arranger and music  producer whose talents shine through in  the recording booth aaron t was voiced  by topher no and this was one of his  first big projects he stated he was  thrilled to be able to learn from such a  highly talented group of people josh  levi provided his voice for aaron z levi  admitted that he didn't know how to read  sheet music and that he just guessed his  way through it i was guessing up a storm